welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the falcon of the winter
soldier is bringing back old faces of
mcu
past the worst of the worst and not just
zemo but
other mystery cameos the cast is
promising
actually falcon's latest returning
villain is thor's arch nemesis from
fortnite and
end game noob master 69. i thought
he's back that kid on the tv just called
me a [ __ ] again
noob master confirmed to be xbox aaron
comedian dc pearson in the latest xbox
commercial featuring
anthony mackie sam wilson himself my
gamer tag is noob master 69.
my cousin made it and in a weird way
this is technically mcu cannon
gamer aaron is a returning captain
america film character
pearson played aaron the apple store guy
and captain america the winner's soldier
i have the exact same glasses wow you
two are practically twins
yeah i wish specimen
uh if you guys need anything i've been
aaron thank you
so now when dick thor screams into the
headset you can imagine aaron on the
other end
new master hey it's thor again you know
the god of thunder
listen buddy if you don't log off this
game immediately i'm gonna fly over to
your house come down to that basement
you're hiding in
rip off your arms and shove them up your
butt oh that's right yes go cry to your
father little weasel
now beyond new master the falcon the
winter soldier promises to bring back
all sorts of mcu faces that we were not
sure we'd ever see again comicbook.com
reported from a virtual press conference
that anthony mackie promised quote
there are many surprises we can't say
who they all
are but there are many surprises now
coming off of wanavision we definitely
have to learn our lessons when it comes
to cast and crew playing the hype game
one movie star's luke skywalker level
cameo is an
art at movie watchers oh this dude
posted on instagram he's gonna be in
this months ago
paul bettany straight up trolled us
promising a major cameo
again and again in interviews just for
it to be his mac os self
elizabeth olson said that even she
thought evan peter scamia was gonna be a
legit fox quicksilver crossover
clearly not on the same page as the
writers so let us just assume going
forward that unless it comes from kevin
feige himself
our best evidence comes from show
footage that we see
on screen and the way past marvel titles
have left doors open
so among the mcu characters confirmed to
return in the falcon of the winter
soldier are
helmut zemo last seen in captain america
civil war successful at using bucky's
history as a hydra assassin
as a wedge turning cap and iron man
against each other
black panther captured him and left him
in a holding cell in the joint
counter-terrorist center in berlin
so how does it feel spend all that time
all that effort
to see it feel so spectacular
did it
zemo will appear in some form in the
series he's now going to be wearing his
purple mask from the comics
i assume we will find out how he escaped
captivity but that
is something that like super villains
always do and we'll find out what his
mission is many believe it's going to be
to assemble a new
team of super anti-heroes similar to the
thunderbolts
now batroc is also returning last seen
on the lemurian star vessel
in the opening sequence of captain
america the winter soldier georgia sapir
was another cast member playing that
whole hype game dude said the fan
theories could be
even bigger than the ones for one
division okay
sharon carter is also coming back last
seen in civil war smooching her
great-aunt's
ex-boyfriend given the stars of this
show quite a show
i'm sure that will come up oh and how
could i forget about
boom you're looking for rudy james
rhodes war machine
don cheadle confirmed back in early
february that he will play a role in
this show
probably going to be a small one i don't
know how much part of the mission in the
action sequences he will be but there
are a few scenes and trailers where it
looks like vip military personnel are
there i could see roadie showing up in
those moments
but if villains like zemo and batroc are
coming back is there a chance we could
see villains from earlier in captain
america's history
like red skull but before we continue
this video was sponsored by expressvpn
are you looking for new stuff to binge
watch or wanting to go back and re-watch
some of your favorites but your
streaming service doesn't have it
if so expressvpn is your solution
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen or tracked and it can grant
you access to blocked content
expressvpn allows you to re-route your
connection to a server in a country of
your choosing
making geo restrictions a thing of the
past like us netflix doesn't have rick
and morty but uk
netflix does well you can open up
yourself to a whole new library of
content without having to pay for a new
streaming service it's faster than
saying
show me what you got expressvpn is also
helpful for preventing your online data
from being stolen or monitored without
your knowledge
i like how super easy expressvpn is to
use
no confusion no wasted time and the
whole thing runs fast just fire up the
app and connect with just one click
it's the top rated vpn provider rated
number one by techradar cnet and many
more
find out how you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by visiting
expressvpn.com
new rockstars or clicking the link in
the description red skull already made
his big surprising comeback and then see
you in avengers infinity war
and an end game as the stone keeper of
vormir his kind of prison sentence for
trying to meddle with the space stone
it's where it blasted him too
but now his whereabouts are unknown ross
marquan took over this role from hugo
weaving in those later films and he said
that the russos told him that thanos and
hawkeye's acquisitions of that soul
stone release
red skull from his servitude you know
once the red skull is released of the
soul stone
once thanos gets it and then once uh
hawkeye gets it
he's essentially free but if we think
about it there's
all these different multiverses now so
in one multiverse
when thanos frees him he's free and i
would imagine the first thing he would
do if he still has a vendetta or any
part of him that still has ambition
would go back to earth i imagine when
you're graced with infinite wisdom
you're also graced or cursed with
infinite pain and
and suffering but that'll be interesting
if he's going to be a force of good or
evil
so this kind of red skull return sounds
a bit too cosmic for the kind of show
the falcon in the winter soldier seems
to be
but what about my man arne mazzola
red skull's henchman who immigrated to
the u.s under project paperclip after
world war ii and then reappeared in the
coolest role
in the winter soldier as an ai algorithm
ghost in the machine
revealing that he or it controlled all
of shield slash hydra
throughout history all the major
political and economic twists
were the result of his algorithm and his
kill list
marvel studios is oddly but luckily for
us
obsessed with zola they have brought
this guy back again
in end game in the 1970 time period as
the person howard stark was looking for
looking for dr zola have you seen him
yeah now dr soul
no haven't haven't haven't seen a soul
and the vfx artist even snuck in
zola's green digital face in the distant
background of this scene
and then after end game end-game
co-writer christopher marcus
continued to chug along on this zola
train saying he wanted to see
a third incarnation of zola in a robotic
body his android form from the comics
that was actually shown
as an easter egg in the blueprints among
his paperwork in that first capped film
on inside marvel the falcon winners
soldier after show mt and i have joked
that this zola train will be
our new mephisto train for the show so
you can stop sending me your mephisto in
the winter room fisto memes they're so
funny but when it comes to zola showing
up on the show
i don't think it's gonna be a toby jones
android i mean who knows maybe
but i would say it's probably more
likely that zola's algorithm face could
flash up on a computer screen you know
just kind of a fun easter egg or
or how about this we hear toby jones
voice in bucky's head as he has
nightmares flashing back to the first
time he got that winter soldier
activation code
because zola would have been the
original author of that code
long in rested seventeen
day break furnace nine ben9
homecoming one freight car now
translates that to russian i'm going to
shove my brain into the computer
and rounding out that cameo speculation
here no
i do not think we will see wolverine in
this series though maybe we might get
some big evidence of mutants beginning
to emerge in this world
and when it comes to maybe a chris evans
captain america cameo
no i don't think he's gonna suit up his
old cap again no i don't think i will we
might get a flashback or an
echo to pass cap moments in the mcu that
they already have as archived but think
about it thematically this series is
more about the absence of steve rogers
the way spider-man far from home was
about the absence of tony stark and his
legacy
in the meantime support this channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for everything marvel
thanks for watching
[Music]
you